hi there steve kaufman
um you know you often hear that there
are different types of learners there
are
auditory learners and visual learners
and
kinetic learners
people like to learn by listening or by
seeing or by doing
books have been written on the subject i
think even
you know
pedagogy has been developed to suit
different kinds of learners
personally
i don't believe that we learn
differently i don't think there are
auditory learners or you know purely
auditory learners or purely visual
learners i think we all learn in all of
these different ways i think the basic
way in which the brain learns is the
same
and there has there a
professor somewhere in the united states
has written on the subject and he he
also has
has is of the same view and has
demonstrated it i think it's a fad
what is true is
that different learners have different
interests
different learners are motivated by
different things
and so
what we should do
i think in language instruction this is
something i alluded to in my previous
video
we should find out you know how how do
we how can we test what kind of profile
can we have
or or a testing procedure to determine
where are the trigger points where are
the things that would motivate learner a
versus learner b versus learner c and
maybe there are different types of
learners
based on what interests them and what
motivates them and maybe there are ways
that we can find out what these things
are and therefore we can motivate
learners
and i think that's the challenge i know
in my own case i always think of those
wonderful pieces of of audio or or
reading
that really grabbed me when i was
learning say chinese i can think of the
things in chinese history or xiangshang
or i can think of a german you know
cassette tape series
where they interviewed people
uh in different walks of life
uh
to me it's always been this interesting
content that grabs me now some people
like to do grammar some people
like to do flashcards so
um
you know how do we find out what kind of
a learner the person is in terms of what
motivates them
i don't think the issue is so much uh
are there different ways in which
different people's brains
work differently to to learn languages i
think it's basically the same the brain
as as i understand it basically has to
get used to the stimulus that it
receives and out of the disorder of all
the stimulus it has to create
patterns
i don't for a minute believe
in chomsky's you know universal grammar
i don't believe that for a minute i
think that
the way we
naturally through listening as children
and hearing the language start to form
patterns and put labels on things and
start to make sense of it is is just the
same way we deal with all the phenomena
that we encounter in life we the brain
has to put
some order to this otherwise every time
they encounter that situation it's new
so so they have to make rules and make
their own rules and and i think we all
all of our brains work the same way
however for whatever reason we have
different interests some people like
sports some people like music some
people like reading some people don't
like reading
so
so i think the key thing there and the
challenge is to try to find out
what
makes people tick when it comes to
language learning and how can you
trigger people and how can you design a
curriculum
that is going to
with 30 different people in the
classroom make sure that each
student
is motivated to the maximum that should
be the challenge in language learning
rather than
uh grammar instruction or drills or
worrying about kinetic learners and
things of that nature anyway that should
stir up a bit of discussion so i look
forward to hearing from you bye for now